Digital fashion is real, and it exists
in somany virtual universes,
ranging from basic social networks
to fully developed virtual worlds
knownas the metaverse.
Because of my gaming
experience, I kept thinking:
“How and why could people
wear digital garments?”
This is when I started experimenting
with what today we know asdigital fashion.
With Carolina Herrera, we
collaborated on a runway dress
and developedan app where you can
wear the dress on your phone
using augmented reality.
And with Jean PaulGaultier,
we collaborated on
a piece that was part of
their couture collection.
Fashion brands areselling
authenticated digital fashion items
that are usually sold out as
soon as they are released.
Balenciaga has collaborated with Fortnite,
and Gucci bag was sold inside Roblox
for morethan its worth in real life.
Fortnite itself has sold more than
two billion worth of skins
and game extras for in-game
character dressing.